[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
tonight our top story a week ago we
hadn't heard of omicron but now it's
spreading rapidly we'll have a special
panel of experts to answer your
questions
sky news is inside the lab studying the
new variant scientists warn it could be
causing a rise in re-infections
once they've grown the virus up to
sufficient quantities out of enough
virus to be able to split up and do
these experiments the first one really
they want to do is to establish
is it going to be
resistant to the vaccine
germany clamps down on the unvaccinated
banning them from shops and bars angela
merkel says a vaccine mandate could be
imposed from february
boris johnson insists christmas events
should not be cancelled as he gets his
kovid booster jab
coming up we'll have a special report on
the front line in a e as medics battle
to treat the massive backlog of nhs
patients also tonight
starved tortured and killed by his
father and stepmother the six-year-old
who died at the hands of those who
should have cared for him
still being kept in the dark thousands
of people are without power following
damage caused by storm irwin
and the duchess of sussex wins her legal
battle against the mail on sunday
calling it a victory for anyone who's
ever felt scared to stand up for what's
right
[Music]
hello there very good evening now do you
go to the christmas party or have a big
family get together the answer may very
well depend on just how serious the
omicron variant is we don't yet know if
the surge in cases in south africa will
lead to a surge in hospital admissions
and what impact it will have around the
world throughout the day we've been
getting your questions about the new
variant which we'll do our best to
answer in a moment but first sky news
has gained rare access to the scottish
laboratory looking at the new covid
variant which is causing concern in the
uk and worldwide scientists at the
facility in glasgow are on the front
line of the race to learn more about the
strain especially how existing vaccines
will perform against it while the
government insists that getting a
covenant booster remains the best
defense and the prime minister received
his this afternoon sky science and
technology editor tom clark has this
from the university of glasgow's center
for virus research
this box contains a precious but
dangerous cargo
this is the omicron sample thank you
scientists here believe it's the first
live sample of the omicron variant
they've been able to obtain
their first chance to confirm in the lab
whether the new variant is as worrying
as it currently looks to the world
outside we don't know yet what the
collection
or the constellation of changes that
we're seeing in this new variant mean
but we will
be able to test that now by taking it
into the laboratory
this high-level containment lab at the
centre for virus research in glasgow is
one of the few in the uk equipped to
handle pathogens like this
it's only once it's inside that the
sample can be carefully unpacked
they've been preparing for this moment
since news of omicron first emerged we
can start straight away to put the virus
in culture in order to plan further
experiments later
because that's very important and this
is the kind of answer we need and we
need scientific data before claiming
anything about how this variant will
behave
so this is an important moment only
getting their hands on a live sample for
the virus will allow these scientists to
start addressing those urgent questions
about the omicron variant can it evade
our vaccines will it be more infectious
than previous variants does it cause
more severe disease
this lab like others around the world
has become expert at infecting human
cells with different variants of kovid19
to assess their unique dangers so on the
right we have cells that are uninfected
and healthy and on the left we have
cells that we've infected with styles
curve 2.
but with reports coming from south
africa of possible infections of omicron
in people previously infected with other
coveted strains the focus has to be on
whether it can avoid our antibodies the
most pressing
is to
be able to understand
how what is the level the degree
that this
omicron can escape
the immunity
elicited by vaccines so you can compare
for example delta
versus omegron and see how the the
antibodies present in the vaccinated
individual can neutralize the virus
however lab tests can only tell us so
much the view among these researchers is
that in the weeks it'll take them to get
results it's best to prepare for the
worst while hoping for the best tom
clark sky news glasgow
well our science correspondent thomas
moore joins me now we know research
being done right around the world on
omicron thomas and i believe in the last
few minutes uh some details coming out
of south africa
yes indeed some of the most important
research in omicron will come from south
africa because that's where they have
the most cases that's where they can do
epidemiological studies and some of the
first evidence is slightly worrying uh
because it they've found that there is a
substantial risk of what they call
immune evasion with this new variant
that means that they can get around the
antibodies that we would have from a
previous infection for example they
found that the reinfection rate was uh
more than twice as high as it was in the
first wave of uh kovid the original
wuhan strain
so that is a concern
because even though in south africa they
do have substantial levels of immunity
antibodies from all the waves they've
had down there people are still highly
likely to get reinfected and that seems
to be what is driving the surge of cases
in south africa now earlier on uh
professor ann von gottenberg from the
national institute for communicable
diseases who did the study uh she also
said that although uh people are
getting reinfected when they are the
symptoms tend to be mild now that is
good news she said and she believes that
would hold true of the vaccine too now
you've got to remember that south
africa's slightly different picture to
the uk they've only got 24 percent of
people vaccinated there compared to our
very high rates and it's possible that
the vaccine will give better protection
against a variant than natural infection
so although we should look very
carefully what's happening there i don't
necessarily conclude that everything
that happens there would happen here
okay thomas uh thank you for the moment
well angela merkel says unvaccinated
people in germany could be barred from
non-essential businesses if the latest
wave of coveted infections isn't broken
the chancellor says it could come into
effect in february let's speak to our
europe correspondent adam parsons who's
in brussels for us so adam it could be
that people have stopped from going into
places like bars sporting events that
sort of thing
yeah in fact there are two things that
have happened in germany today two big
announcements uh and if we unpick them
one is about
exactly
as you were just saying effectively a
lockdown for the
unvaccinated now this could actually
come into play uh pretty shortly and and
this would see people who have
effectively chosen not to take the
vaccine
being barred from essential shops being
barred from from leisure and culture
facilities
while their friends and relatives who
have been vaccinated are allowed into
those shops i don't think there's any
way of
presenting that as anything other than a
two-tier society
effectively this is not so much a nudge
to people to try to get them vaccinated
as a massive wallop in the back now
critics will say that this is
stigmatizing to them supporters i think
would probably uh agree but i think
there is some unease about the idea of
telling people that they can't live a
the same life as others
i have to say there are plenty in german
society who support that poll suggest
that that will get uh we'll get pretty
popular support the other thing that the
germans have announced today is the
proposal for mandatory vaccination it's
a bit more complicated this one it would
have to go through the german parliament
the bundestag
it has the backing of angela merkel
chancellor at least the chancellor now
she's about to leave that job she says
she would support that even though in
the past she said that this really has
to be a voluntary process but her
successor olaf schultz also supports
this uh he's pretty much in charge now
and he said it will be a free vote in
the bundesliga but he thinks it is
likely to go through
and i think this could have huge
implications now austria has already
said that it will follow this process of
a mandatory vaccination but to be blunt
there is one thing for austria to do it
quite another for germany that the
richest and most populous country in the
european uh union a country that has
been led for so long by angela merkel a
fairly cautious leader now by oliver
schultz somebody who is also not given
uh to these big bits of theater that you
get from uh let's say emmanuel macron or
boris johnson that neither of those
people would have wanted to do this to
bring in mandatory vaccinations or
indeed this this two-tier form of
society it tells you a lot about
germany's problems that they aren't
prepared to embrace this what are those
problems big surge in cases recently
largely in the east of germany and
germany is not alone we're seeing
similar rises in cases in other
countries france which has done pretty
well to recently has seen a spike uh
over the past few days john cassette the
prime minister there has called a
meeting of his health defense council
for monday there are plenty of changes
around europe at the moment it is a
patchwork of slightly different rules
from country to country but one thing
that everyone will be watching
is what happens in germany
okay adam many thanks well it's been a
busy day of news about omicron let's try
and unpick some of it as promised we've
got a panel of experts tonight i'm
joined by the professor of pediatrics at
the university of bristol and member of
the joint committee on vaccination
immunisation adam finn senior clinical
lecturer at exeter university and public
health expert dr barat pancania and the
gp dr rosemary leonard great to see you
all this evening thank you very much for
giving us your time and trying to answer
some of the questions that we've had
through to us at sky news today let's
crack on with those questions shall we
perhaps starting with you professor finn
this question from julia bolston now
julia says as a mother of a 20 month old
how worried should i be about omicron
what do scientists and doctors say about
the effects of the new variant on young
children
uh well of course we're still only just
learning about omicron at the moment but
i think i can be very reassuring uh to
this to julia on this question because
one of the things that we've seen
consistently through this pandemic is
that children are much more mildly
affected than adults and very much more
mildly affected than elderly adults by
this virus
and the younger the children are the
less
likely they are to get seriously ill so
it would be a very big surprise to see
that trend change with this new variant
and we've certainly not heard any
reports of serious illness in children
from south africa so far nor seen any in
europe yes good news isn't it let's hope
that continues and just staying with you
professor finn how how long do you think
before
uh vaccines are brought in in the uk for
young children not not 20 month old
children obviously but five year olds
and above
so we're expecting uh a
verdict from the mhra as to whether or
not the younger children whether vaccine
can be authorized for younger children
and as soon as that comes through it'll
be being discussed by the jcvi so a
decision on that should be expected
certainly before christmas yeah dr
leonard it's very hard isn't it for
parents because of course all parents
want answers they want to know what the
best thing is for their children but
when they come and see you and ask
questions like this you simply don't
have the answers yet
no but we we do have some answers as the
professor said we know that in very
young children and in school-aged
children serious illness from covet is
extremely rare so i think parents can be
reassured about that um we have parents
who are worried about side effects from
the vaccine and i look forward to
hearing the recommendation of the jcvi
as to whether the risk of the disease of
covid is is is greater than actually any
risk of the vaccine it's quite going to
be a very finely judged decision but i
think parents can be reassured that
actually this isn't the vast vast
majority of children this is not a
serious illness
okay let's move on to another question
and this is sort of looking looking
ahead really um
and dr kanye perhaps you can help us
with this one it's from dean in slough
and dean asks what advice would you give
to the government to try and avoid more
problematic variants that could arise in
the future so even beyond omicron
so what we have to know is the natural
history of viruses
and it isn't advice to the government
but it is advised to all governments and
whilst you can get in
a a random mutation a mutation you must
read it as a mistake which then becomes
favorable to the virus and it becomes a
new variant that can happen at any place
anywhere anytime in the world having
said that the probabilities of having
variants emerge are under the following
circumstances where you have a lot of
infections where you have a prolonged
infection where you have a prolonged
infection in somebody who is immune
suppressed and where you have those
prolonged infections in an immune
suppressed person that mistake upon
mistake upon mistake meaning mutation in
a person who is who is generating
several generations of the virus can
lead to the emergence of a variant so
what should we be doing
this is a global issue and the global
issue and especially with the
richer nations is this
we are not well until all of us are well
and we have failed in uh this this this
task of uh immunizing ourselves as well
as helping africa and other parts of the
world to also suppress their infections
so the answer to dean and slav is
we
all the nations especially the richer
nations with the who need to work harder
a lot harder and suppress infections
globally and if we suppress infections
globally we reduce the chances of such
variants arising again yeah and just
staying with you what do you make of
this news that we've just heard coming
out of south africa uh that there is a
substantial risk of immune evasion with
omicron reinfection rates uh seem to be
twice as high as the original wuhan
strain
so it is of much concern if it is
vaccine bypassing in other words the
antibodies made by our vaccines are not
able to latch on to the virus and
neutralize it so it is of concern
however what i want to say is it won't
be a 100 vaccine escape that is highly
highly unlikely so marginally the
efficacy may drop by say 10 15 20
but you are still protected by the
existing vaccines and the booster will
be giving you a additional enhanced
immunity
furthermore your t cells will also be
being boosted so at the moment the best
thing you can do is be fully immunized
including your booster and take other
infection control measures and if we
have
if we have to reformulate the vaccines
we can reformulate them but we only
reformulate them if it is absolutely
necessary
okay um
dr leonard this is this is a a tricky
one uh uh uh for for uh experts such as
yourselves to answer but i'm gonna
answer it and ask it anyway because it's
something that so many people are
thinking about um when is south africa
likely to be removed from the red list
for uk citizens who've booked to see
family this christmas should we cancel
our flights that coming from madeleine
once again just as we thought travel was
was resuming returning to normal it's
all um in disarray again yeah i mean and
unfortunately this is impossible for me
to answer it will only be possible to
know when travel will be
freed up again actually not only south
africa but across europe when we know
just just the effects of this variant
just how is it more infectious does it
cause more serious disease and
unfortunately at the moment it's a
question of we've got to be patient
we've got to wait for the scientists to
do their work and we can't try and jump
the gun and say oh yes it will suddenly
be freed up we just don't know we've got
to be patient and i know people don't
like living with the unknown but that's
what we've got to do right now yeah i
mean it's the message isn't it that
we're hearing over and over again it's a
sort of watch and wait scenario
adam finn um
the u.n secretary general today it was
quite interesting i thought said that
restrictions isolating individual
countries are ineffective and even went
as far as saying it's travel apartheid
um many would say surely a much better
system of of of testing being absolutely
rigorous with that would be better than
than the situation we've got at the
moment where
countries are sort of randomly being
picked and told no we don't want anyone
coming
uh well i think there is a certain uh
randomness to this in a way the i i
certainly think that uh
colleagues in south africa have helped
us a great deal by giving us information
very promptly about this variant which
almost certainly didn't originate in
south africa
but it was them their vigilance that
brought it to the world's attention um
and i suspect that it's quite widely
distributed around the world and the
more testing is done the more we'll find
of it
so
yes uh on the other hand i can see why
travel restrictions being brought in
simply because of the experience at the
beginning of the pandemic when we saw
such rapid propagation of the virus
around the world and people
wish that they'd been
quicker to restrict that from happening
at the beginning but you're right that
an effective way of testing and tracing
and trying to reduce transmission is the
ideal approach to this and that's
clearly what we're trying to do in this
country at the moment yeah because of
course we all know the the huge economic
impact that shutting off international
travel can have uh thank you all for the
moment do stay with us we're going to
take a break in a moment but plenty more
questions to come we can take a look now
at some of the latest that covert data
for you let's bring that in
and show you the latest numbers it shows
that 53
945 new cases of covert 19 have been
recorded in the latest 24-hour period a
further 141 people have also died this
brings the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
to 145 281. 26 028 people received their
first dose of a vaccine while 32 356
people received their second dose and
that brings the total number of people
to have received their second dose to
more than 46.4
million and 407 851
booster and third jabs were given in the
latest 24-hour period including the
prime minister of course taking the
total number of those doses to just over
19 million
the nationwide infection rate now stands
at 436 weekly cases per 100 000 people
virtually unchanged in fact from the
previous week the place with the highest
case rate is torijin devon with 1049
cases per 100 000 people aside from the
scottish islands the place with the
lowest rate is keradian in wales with
220 cases per
100 000 people
will do stay with us for this special
omicron question and answer special
coming up after this short break our
panel will be staying with us to answer
more of your questions don't go away
[Music]
it's it's something that's been going on
since 1876 uh okay the uh the grave
squirrels bought the
the vaccine bought the virus into the
the country and then
it's just been ripping through the red
scroll population for about 150 years so
from the population of about
3 million red squirrels we're now down
to about 120 000 and the situation is
just getting worse
there are gray scrolls but there's a lot
of protection um
it's a
it's a national trust
site so they've got rangers going around
trapping the grace
having said that the
the virus has been in there but they've
managed to control the graze again the
population slowly build up
we believe because there's about three
million grey squirrels the
chances of controlling their numbers in
the short term are very slim
so the best way to protect the red
squirrels
is to develop a vaccine against the
virus
you can have
gray squirrels living in contact with
red skulls but in time
the red squads will disappear
but if those grey squirrels have got the
virus the red scrolls disappeared 25
times more quickly so unless we can get
a vaccine into the red squirrels we're
going to continue to die in agony you
know as long as the gray scrolls are
around
we're trying to raise 1.2 million pounds
and we believe that will actually get
the vaccine out into the field
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
who take you to the heart of stories
that shape our world
[Music]
hello again welcome back to sky news
tonight we're answering your questions
about the omicron variant and i'm joined
by the professor of pediatrics at the
university of bristol a member of the
joint committee on vaccination and
immunization adam finn senior clinical
lecturer at exeter university and public
health expert dr brat pancania and also
the gp dr rosemi leonard great to see
you all again uh dr leonard why don't we
start part two with you i'm sure you've
been asked this question a number of
times uh jeanette griffis has been in
touch to say what extra precautions to
the panel advise the clinically
vulnerable take when it comes to the new
variant
the
the answer is carry on doing what you're
doing now we don't know if this new
variant is any more dangerous to the
clinically vulnerable than the delta
variant certainly clinically vulnerable
people should absolutely make sure they
are fully vaccinated many of the really
vulnerable people should have had three
vaccines as their primary course
and then we think that the advice after
that hasn't really been clarified but
they will probably then need a fourth
dose maybe a fifth dose best thing to do
is to ask their own individual doctors
and also with christmas coming just to
have a think about how much you want to
intermingle with other people and if
you've got a family gathering round
maybe it would be sensible for the other
family members to do lateral flow tests
before they visit those who are
clinically vulnerable to keep the risk
of transmission of the virus to those at
risk as as low as possible rosemary is
your surgery having a christmas party
this year
we are indeed we we are we didn't have
one last year we've all been working
closely together but we are hiring quite
a big space we don't envisage us hugging
each other there certainly won't be any
mistletoe um
we won't be
you know i mean there's been a lot in
the news today about mistletoe and we
won't be having any
no okay and of course we're all being
told now that we need to wear masks um
adam
where is the evidence on on wearing
masks now because it's caused quite a
bit of a row hasn't it in recent days
some people saying that the evidence
simply isn't there and why should their
freedoms be impinged on what what do you
say
uh well i'm fortunate having a very
distinguished colleague uh who
researches aerosols here in bristol
and jonathan reed and he's
shared the latest evidence with us
recently it's it's very very clear that
wearing a mask will reduce the chances
of you infecting other people when you
have this and indeed other respiratory
viruses of which there are a lot around
at the moment so you can reduce the
risks to people around you by wearing a
mask
if you wear the kind of uh
mask that we use in hospital the ffp2s
you can actually protect yourself
because you can seal
the mask around your nose and mouth and
and you can filter out some of the
droplets that are in the air but wearing
a mask any kind of mask will reduce the
chances of you
infecting people around you and i think
there's really no question about that
okay um dr pancania a question for you
this is an interesting one from thiru do
we know the vaccine status of the people
who have contracted omicron in the uk we
know more cases have been
announced this evening but do we know
whether or not they were vaccinated
if you had asked me that question
tomorrow i would have said i know the
answer because i've got an incident
meeting tomorrow
having said that
looking at the evidence from
other parts of the world we do know
especially from south africa that people
who have been fully immunized have got
infected with the omicron variant that's
nothing unusual because you can get
fully you can be fully immunized and get
infected so we don't know we don't know
for the uk people but the message is of
course you can get infected even if you
have been fully immunized yeah it's
interesting the debate um
dr leonard isn't it about uh mandatory
vaccines something which may well come
in
in germany uh and elsewhere what are
your thoughts on that
well we're already seeing it that those
who are working in the nhs and in social
care by next april they must be fully
vaccinated and i know people see this as
a sort of a violation of their human
rights if you like but i think we will
be seeing we're we're in a time of war
we're in a time of a biological war
and that comes when we have to say what
is the best for society and and some of
our rights do do seem to go away we have
to accept there are sacrifices we have
to make and i think we will be seeing in
the uk
more and more employers particularly
insisting that their their workforce is
vaccinated to protect the others around
them as much as anything else i mean so
i speak to a lot of people who haven't
been vaccinated and they say well it
doesn't matter to me i'm willing to take
that chance the problem is if they're
working with other people who are more
vulnerable and they spread the virus to
them so yes there are a lot of ethical
questions about it but i can see us
moving more in the direction of other
european countries and insisting more on
vaccination
okay i know we've got to say goodbye to
you you've got to dash off dr asimi
leonard gp uh in west allis in london
thank you very much indeed uh um
uh dr ban kanye i saw you shaking your
head there what are your thoughts on
this
so look i've been uh in the business for
30 years immunizing uh children and i
know all about the mmr
debacle that we had and how worried
mothers were with taking the vaccine or
not taking it and i tell you i have done
this for over 30 years i spoke to my
patients
i educated them i informed them i told
them about the pluses and minuses of the
vaccines and
i took them with me i have a long track
record of taking most of my patients
with me
i feel very disturbed about forcing
people to have vaccines because this is
a long-term thing i don't want to
alienate my patients i don't want to
alienate people i want them to be
informed and i want them to make those
choices voluntarily i think it is a
failure it's a failure of politicians
health officers
people like myself in public health of
informing advising educating people
about the benefits of the vaccine and we
should do that first before we mandate
it
very interesting okay thank you very
much for that um one final question um
i'll direct this uh professor adam finn
we've touched on christmas parties
already but of course as we approach
christmas it is a question many people
are asking isn't it including uh uh
srilane who says should large gatherings
like christmas parties be cancelled it's
risking vulnerable people in our
families
this is a tricky one to answer
of course we're hearing mixed messages
from different advisors on this
i can give you my personal view and that
is that i will not be going to any
christmas parties this year i've got a
lot of people who work with me and i
very much like their company and i like
to
celebrate the end of the year but i
think with the prospect of another wave
as a very real potential problem coming
up we should all be doing absolutely
everything we can to minimize
transmission both of the delta variant
that we've got at the moment and
potentially this new omicron variant so
the more you can do to reduce
transmission over the next few weeks
the better and
i think christmas parties is one of
those things that we can probably manage
without
okay very interesting uh doctor pancana
nodding his head as well we must leave
it there but it's been great getting
your thoughts uh and getting your
answers to our viewers questions adam
finn professor of pediatrics at the
university of bristol dr brat ban kanye
senior clinical lecturer at exeter
university uh and uh dr rosemary leonard
who left a little earlier thank you both
very much indeed really good to get your
thoughts this evening
so there we are very interesting indeed
plenty more coming up here on sky news
tonight including we've been given
exclusive access to an emergency
department as staff struggle to manage
the backlog of patients caused by the
pandemic that's
[Music]
[Music]
you